[Música]
damos paso a revista de prensa recibimos
en el estudio un día más a Marta Moya
bienvenida Hola Rosa Buenos días Buenos
días Marta y empezamos de nuevo
comentando titulares protagonizados por
el expresidente Donald Trump que no da
tregua a las redacciones internacionales
no Y empezamos viendo precisamente como
el medio político aborda la condena que
emitió yo ayer no la corte Federal de
Manhattan que digamos ocupó hallo
culpable al ex mandatario de difamación
y abuso sexual contra la escritora Jenny
Así es rosa Donald Trump no nos da
tregua tampoco a nosotros y un día más
aquí estamos reportando sobre sus
hazañas vamos a empezar con político
porque ayer recordemos no el tribunal
Federal de Manhattan condenó a Trump por
lo que decías difamación y abuso sexual
contra la escritora y Jim Carroll y por
esta condena tendrá que pagar 5 millones
a la escritora Aunque ha dicho que va a
recurrir la sentencia político dice más
que también otros expresidentes como
biden o Bill Clinton han sido acusados
anteriormente por abusos sexual y marca
una diferencia entre la condena civil y
la condena penal porque la condena al
expresidente Donald Trump por este caso
es una condena civil y dice que un caso
civil es más difícil que el tribunal no
considere probados los hechos que
expresa la persona demandante sin
embargo en un caso penal la justicia
tiene que comprobar al 100% que el
acusado cometo cometió los delitos por
los que es acusado no Además dice que
las limitaciones penales contra o sea
por isin Carroll porque han pasado 20
años por el caso impidieron que fuera
que se pudiera tramitar por la vía penal
y por lo tanto fue por la vía civil dice
Además este artículo de político que
para quienes siguieron el caso de cerca
esta sentencia estaba bastante Clara por
la eficiencia y la solvencia del equipo
de abogados de isin car y porque el
equipo de Trump ni presentó a testigos y
se dedicó a hostigar a la escritora y
Marta tanto este caso como los otros que
tiene abiertos a Donald Trump abren un
poco el debate sobre si van a afectar a
los deseos no del ex presidente de
precisamente volver a concurrir a la
presidencia por el partido republicano
en 2024 y en esto se centra un poco el
New York Times no Así es rosa y el Times
dice textualmente no hay mundo en que el
resultado de este juicio civil haya sido
un avance positivo para el proyecto
presidencial de Trump sin embargo dice
que el expresidente ya tiene un largo
historial de comentarios misóginos y
groseros que no evitaron ni que fuera
presidente en 2016 y de que casi lo
fuera en 2020 ni de que sea el candidato
republicano mejor postulado para las
elecciones de 2024 además recordemos que
son 26 las mujeres que han acusado a
Donald Trump a lo largo de los años por
conductas sexuales inapropiadas esta
noche además el candidato tend una
aparición estelar en la CNN en New
hampshire donde probablemente va a
acusar a ishine Carroll de que todo es
mentira y de que ni siquiera la conoce
Esto será un palco muy positivo para el
expresidente donde probablemente será
visto por millones de estadounidenses en
la Esfera del rival rondesantes sí que
consideran que este caso puede ser un
distintivo de otros escándalos del
expresidente sin embargo otros miembros
del partido republicano siguen diciendo
que todo esto Solo es un una víctima de
un complot Donald Trump y Marta los
titulares que deje esta entrevista de la
CNN seguro que nos las traes mañana aquí
en esta sección vamos con Liberación que
precisamente hace un repaso de lo que
comentabas no de esta larga lista de
casos que tiene Donald Trump Sí Rosa Por
qué no es infinita pero se le acerca
dice Liberación cualquier otro candidato
después de esta sentencia desaparecería
para siempre de la carrera presidencial
sin embargo Trump es el primer ex
ocupante de la Casa Blanca en acusado
por lo civil también es el primer ex
jefe de estado acusado de 34 delitos por
soborno a la actriz pornos a la espera
de evaluar su papel en el asalto al
Capitolio del 6 de junio del 6 de enero
perdón de 2021 supresión sobre los
políticos de Georgia para trastocar los
resultados de las elecciones de 2020 la
tenencia de documentos clasificados o
sus delitos fiscales por sus actividades
empresariales si Marta y precisamente a
él parece que le dé fuerza no por este
argumento que tú misma comentabas de que
siempre lo acaba tildando de un poco de
una instrumentalización y de una víctima
se acaba haciendo la víctima no de un
complot político y de Guardian nos habla
de este del impacto que podrían tener
finalmente estos casos en las elecciones
pues sí rosa de garganta hace un
análisis sobre si este caso y esta
condena por lo civil va a tener un
impacto real en las elecciones o en esa
carrera presidencial para postularse
como candidato republicano en 2024 dice
que lo más
sorprendente del caso en Estados Unidos
es la imperturbabilidad que supone una
condena de estas dimensiones contra un
expresidente que ayer no hubo ni
demócratas ni republicanos clamando
porque Donald Trump se retirará de la
carrera por las primarias y que además
en una encuesta reciente publicada eso
sí antes de la condena Trump sacaba 18
puntos porcentuales a biden en una
carrera en la carrera presidencial y que
es poco probable que este veredicto
tenga un impacto negativo en la base
republicana pero los demócratas podrían
utilizar esa grabación de la declaración
de Donald Trump en este juicio para
hacer campaña y hacer vídeos electorales
y además atraer así a los votantes
independientes ya martes que sí a su
propio partido le beneficia no toda esta
exposición pues
claramente no lo van a apartar bueno
cambiamos de tema vamos al país de
España que hizo una entrevista al
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez con un gran abanico de
temas por delante Sí Rosa
es una entrevista enmarcada en que ayer
el secretario general de Naciones Unidas
recibió el premio europeo Carlos V en
España que premia la labor de las
personas o las organizaciones para
defender el europeísmo y en esta
entrevista Pues nos deja grandes
titulares y se enmarca en tres
cuestiones principales la guerra en
Ucrania la situación y la emergencia
climática y los flujos migratorios sobre
la guerra en Ucrania Gutiérrez aseguró
que no ve posible en estos momentos unas
negociaciones de paz entre Rusia y
Ucrania sostiene además que el papel que
está haciendo la ONU literalmente en la
medida de lo posible es tener un diálogo
con las dos partes para solucionar
problemas concretos como el acuerdo de
granos que recordemos expira el próximo
18 de mayo y asegura que están
trabajando en ello y que Próximamente va
a haber una reunión entre las partes
Rusia Ucrania y las mediadoras la ONU y
Turquía además dice que esto pretende
lograr una prolongación de la iniciativa
duradera
perfecta y además asegura que zaporilla
sigue siendo el escenario más complejo
de la guerra en Ucrania y que genera más
preocupación a las autoridades
internacionales valoro también el papel
de china como mediador y Marta como
comentabas también otro de los temas
abordados Es el cambio climático y una
crítica sobre cómo Europa gestionaba sus
fronteras y los flujos migratorios
firrosa sobre el clima dijo que si
Europa está o el mundo está condenado a
abandonar los acuerdos de París que
recordemos implican que la temperatura
global no aumente más de 1.5 grados en
lo que viene de siglo dice que hay que
cambiar dramáticamente lo que hacemos
para lograr resultados efectivos y
además sobre los flujos migratorios
hecho la culpa a Europa sobre su cierre
de fronteras y dijo que el sur global es
mucho más receptivo y mucho más acogedor
con los refugiados y que Europa también
tendría que repensar la manera en la que
hace las políticas migratorias para que
sea más inclusivo y que pueda acoger
a más refugiados no solo de Ucrania sino
también del sur global Claro que sí
Marta sin ir más lejos no muchas
personas sudanesas que se encuentran
expulsadas y rechazadas por las
autoridades europeas en las fronteras
Muchas gracias por esta revista de
prensa Gracias Rosa